economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio luis méndez luis muy buenas
noches vamos a comenzar con detalles del
fin de la gira por europa del presidente
de argentina alberto fernández cómo le
fue al mandatario de acuerdo con medios
argentinos de en este caso como ámbito
financiero y clarín los objetivos del
viaje fueron cumplidos adicionalmente
estos refieren la posibilidad de que el
presidente sostenga un encuentro con la
directora gerente del fondo monetario
internacional kristalina georgieva el
día de mañana sería la primera vez que
el mandatario argentino se reúne con la
titular del fondo monetario
internacional puede recordar que desde
hace algunos meses una misión del
organismo multilateral viene
desarrollando conversaciones técnicas
con el gobierno argentino especialmente
con su ministro de economía martín
guzmán de cara a encontrar una solución
viable al pago de la deuda que asciende
a más de 44 mil millones de dólares pero
en medio de esta noticia el instituto
nacional de estadísticas y censos de
argentina dio a conocer que la inflación
subió 41 por ciento respecto a marzo en
el mes de abril y con ello se sitúa en
17,6
entre enero y el cuarto mes del año de
2021 además acumula un alza de 46 3% en
los últimos 12 meses hablamos ahora de
méxico y eeuu hay tensión entre estos
dos países en cuanto a temas laborales
qué es lo que sucede hay que recordar
que días atrás de eeuu pidió a méxico en
el marco del acuerdo revisar el caso de
trabajadores de una fábrica de camiones
a los que se le habrían negado la
posibilidad de asociarse libremente o de
una negociación colectiva esta sería la
primera vez que washington inicia por sí
mismo una disputa laboral en el marco
del nuevo acuerdo a través de un
comunicado la representante comercial de
eeuu catering time informó la
importancia del acuerdo para proteger la
libertad de asociación y los derechos de
negociación colectiva en mexico por su
parte méxico ha respondido con un
comunicado en el que entre otras cosas
señala una falta de aplicación en las
leyes laborales dentro de la industria
agrícola estadounidense el texto también
detalla la preocupación del gobierno
mexicano en temas como el procesamiento
y empacado de proteínas por parte de
estados
y mire usted brasil el gigante
suramericano va a llevar a cabo una
importante cooperación en el sector
agrícola con uno de los países más
pequeños de suramérica guyana
santiago es una información que se
desprende de un comunicado emitido por
el instituto interamericano de
cooperación para la agricultura luego de
una reunión en la que participaron
representantes tanto de brasil como de
cuchara de acuerdo con la nota cuyana
según sus autoridades se erige como
líder agrícola dentro del bloque del
caricom por otro lado brasil se ha
convertido en uno de los países más
importantes del planeta en términos de
producción y comercio agropecuario y
guyana es un importante proveedor de
alimentos principalmente para el caribe
así lo destacó el director del organismo
manuel otero por su parte teresa
christina que es la ministra de la
agricultura ganadería y abastecimiento
de brasil señaló que la agenda contiene
aspectos como la defensa agropecuaria
asistencia técnica investigación y
acciones para la agricultura familiar
hablemos ahora del bitcoin malas
noticias en la jornada de hoy es un
anuncio del sello de la empresa tesla
provocó una caída de 12 por ciento al
inicio de la jornada en los mercados
pero ésta se redujo ya sobre el final a
6%
tesla anunció que dejará de recibir
pagos en sus vehículos en bitcoins una
declaración que va en contra de lo
anunciado en el mes de marzo cuando
aceptaba el pago de la cripta moneda
algo que provocó su mayor valor
histórico en un tuit nos indicó que pese
a creer en los escritos monedas le
preocupa que ello puede impulsar un
aumento masivo en el uso de combustibles
fósiles por otro lado
tesla anunció que retendría la script o
monedas especiales
bitcoin con la finalidad de utilizarlas
tan pronto como la minería pase a
fuentes de energía sustentables y
siempre hay unos que les va bien en
medio de la crisis y ejemplo de esto es
el crecimiento del comercio entre china
y rúsia y es que de acuerdo con el
ministerio de comercio de china el
intercambio entre estos dos países se
elevó a 19 8% interanual en los primeros
4 meses del presente año el dato
corresponde a un intercambio de 40 mil
210 millones de dólares siendo ésta la
primera vez que supera la barrera de los
mil millones en los primeros meses de un
año indicadores por supuesto que
cerraron de manera positiva en eeuu
borrando las pérdidas del día de ayer
por otro lado en europa también hubo
cierres positivos no así en el mercado
japonés que volvió a cerrar en rojo en
américa latina hubo recuperación en los
mercados cerraron de manera positiva
muchas gracias luis es todo por el
momento en la economía en france24 siga
con nosotros buenas noches
sí
[Música]